hey guys wanna set your machine Mitchell
over new set new set everybody will be
together again hey guys we're on set
with shame I feel like we've never dude
again I don't want to hear hey guys it's
Matt Babel here with Shay Mitchell
another fellow behind the scenes of her
new movie cadaver shooting in Fort
Devens
Shay Shay is a long way from Rosewood in
her new film where she plays an ex-cop
working the graveyard shift in the
morgue and must fight off an evil entity
this is behind the scenes on the next
shot that I could be in and some things
go down in the cooler room where they
store all the bodies show us this room
so do you have a different understanding
like are you learning things I see
scalpels and all this kind of medical
stuff Ryan I am learning dialog and
language I'm learning so much I mean it
was kind of creepy I didn't know if I
actually wanted to go to a real Mort
yeah did do a little bit of that yeah um
that was interest you were in a real
Mort as well yeah yeah that must been
super weird very weird but this is very
close to that feeling it looks almost
exactly like it and then to be pushing
cadavers into these cooling systems is
crazy
yeah like hold on here's what we're
gonna do right now I'm gonna hold
something up and you're gonna tell me
what it is this is a that is a this is
this is a what I was second is not what
that is this is a that's a drill this is
a drill is that what they call it though
hey is it weird that you're shooting in
a morgue there's dead bodies it's a
high-stress situation
then you're gonna go and eat a sandwich
and just step off set and act like
nothing's happening no no it's not you
carry any emotion but do you carry any
emotional yeah I'm so worried Austin's
in this movie that I did carry it with
me a little bit when I came home you
have to sort of shake it off a little
bit especially when we're here for 12
hours and playing this character the
clothes are when I go home I like to
shake it off and get back to Shay I need
to shake it off you